huh is it off now it's so cold I'm
getting my feet they're cold cold
leaning back to the stream everybody we
are raising money for Save the Children
we're back we're gonna do some body art
with some blow pens welcome to be to
blow your friends we just started off
with a nice bucket because I law I got a
punishment in the bobbing for apples
punishment container if we can get a
sweet shot of that bobbing for apples
punishment container that is a whole
list of stuff we've already done for
punishments already and we've got a lot
more on the way but that doesn't mean
that we're done yet because we've got
one more we just hit 40,000 while we're
on break and so we're starting up again
so if you guys can help us out the new
hash tag for this stream is hash tag
Babcock in honor of Andrew Babcock who
is the first thousand dollar donation
today thank you so much for that we are
going to be celebrating everything that
we're doing today with that hash tag use
that on Twitter to share around the
stream share around the tilt to fight
page which I tweeted out and post it on
Facebook so please retweet that share on
hashtag Babcock and share the Facebook
page and share this stream as well I'm
gonna go change shirts and we're gonna
get this body art underway cuz he has to
have that stove I'll be right uh wait if
we hit 40,000 we got to figure out who's
gonna be doing the next punishment well
I think it should come full circle and
it should be you know I've already done
three punishment drew haven't done three
I've had to go bobbing three times yeah
but only two of them actually affected
you yeah and you guys have had one each
that's not fair so I have electricity
hooked up to my body currently I don't
think it's safe for me to go in though
we can turn that off no we can't never
as we can
we can I believe in us but in the
meantime the charity we're raising money
for us Save the Children everything is
worth double we doubled the stakes for
this stream we doubled everything
because each time you contribute up to
$200,000 we have an anonymous donor that
is going to match every donation up to
that amount what anyway so everything is
worth double shares getting more people
in getting donations and doing
everything you can because we everything
is worth double this time around and we
doubled the goal to try and match the
maximum donation amount we can have for
Save the Children which is a wonderful
wonderful charity we are doing
switching between live streams and going
off because we are doing various
different activities the schedule full
schedule is on the till to 5 page so
definitely check it out go over that you
can also donate to get limited edition
exclusive old school shirts they are the
last ones we have there a limited number
there are 50 dollars each and roughly
about 43 dollars out of that 50 goes
directly to the charity e hey sake
shorts socks my underwears
it looks like myself it does i no one
heard of things so who knows what that
was okay so yes as Tyler was saying we
were raising money for Save the Children
we are doing incredibly we're already at
41 thousand dollars and first off before
we get started we have to celebrate the
people that donated extremely high
amounts starting with Holtzman with a
thousand anonymous with a thousand and
Brandon and Johanna with eight hundred
dollars donated so we're gonna start
with Holtzman who's next
what you already Bob so many no no no
you fool no the writing mine I'm okay
fool give me a sweet bicep all right
Holtzman all right you want to do it no
well yeah sure actually no all right
right along the bicep wherever you would
like all right here we go
Holtzman thank you for the nation holds
me get that flexing that the donation
guns oh hell yeah yeah now next up is
anonymous whoo I like it I guess it's my
turn is it yeah yes prison on anyone all
right
would you like it give me an anonymous
Tran stamp all right all right you want
that big and on oh you know you know
I wonder what you look like
books are important you ask your
personality obviously is good
[Music]
yey-hey now Brandon and Johanna
give me just a good BJ BJ good but hold
on hold on hold on let me let me show
you how I want it let me show you what I
want no I am the artist okay I don't
care well I mean when you go to a tattoo
parlor
you kind of do I don't just go let's go
through got here I want something like
that okay all right all right I can do
that all right where are we where are we
going with that back to your neck
no your mouth lips your lips just right
on those right in there no just just
want to just one of those nice big nice
shoulder dude I think this should be
more of a bob so Brandon and Johanna you
are really cool Brennan into Anna you
are not a full thing - they were really
cool and weird you alot sink legs all
have some fun together and what body
aren't on each other it is really true
we're cool you are cool I sleep are cool
and everyone Laurie we are cool and then
what is the one we love and no it's cool
cool cool cool cool it's hard to draw my
shoulder and put it around a giant BJ
would you draw a better heart is that
even a heart and enjoy it all right so
please if you can make donations down in
the description below it is gonna be an
incredible help to this cause Save the
Children is an amazing charity and if
you can please please make a donation
everything that you do is doubled the
link is right down there in the
description I've shared the donation
page on Twitter on Facebook we've got a
long way to go we we made incredible
progress in the first hour of this
stream but we have so much more to do
and if you guys help us we will reach
this goal and we're gonna smash through
it non-stop so thank you everybody that
has and really if you can't make a
donation what you can do is you can help
us by sharing the stream and reaching
out to someone
because even if the donations are
doubles your actions can double
everything just by reaching one more
person that can make a donation asking a
family member asking a friend asking
anyone that can help is gonna do
immensely and because we reach $35,000
we have unlocked another punishment
another delightful blow Oh No let's uh
get a new Apple in here I think you
should excuse you
yeah oh oh god damn it
scuse you get out of the way take take a
good gander it just near my elbow Oh
ruckus so we're gonna add this in that's
right that's nice who's Bobby it's you
are why we decided what no I just did a
punishment [ __ ] you excuse you I'm
electrocuted right now I can't do it
Babcock ampere you proved Langer's
didn't really last I've already gone
into the thing three times well this is
hardly fair I don't think so all right
fine
but that doesn't mean that I'm gonna
give you the punishment so I came up
with a punishment so I get to make the
room no you need to be punished more oh
yeah okay 20 is in the bucket it hurts
to move my move okay whatever all right
all right well I gotta go in again yeah
all right give it a good mix give it a
mess good it makes me I trust him I
trust he'll be fair all right here we go
I'll be fair
okay use that use that gaper yeah oh
he's got one in his mouth can you suck
it in suck that Apple into your mouth
bite it oh you're really going in there
that was like a full no hands sorry
oh no no now we're on a different one oh
he's just licking it he's just looking
at as a whole he's a good ball ball yeah
yeah yeah thank yes thanks
oh he got one 17:03 gingka after you
already said she wasn't no chica come
here chica yeah to get okay we love you
alright so she could torture it's not
actual physical torture it's emotional
torture we have right here uncooked
steak we hadn't cooked it yet I'm gonna
start I'm gonna put it on the bar and
pop it on that grill but first get let
chica know what she's in store for chica
we have something for you or we have
something to show you and not give you
kind of make it so she can give it a
good sniff yeah chica you see this oh oh
you wanted oh no she wants it
no no chicky you can't have it not until
we reach the next donation threshold to
get another punishment we have to reach
50,000 before chief you can get this
delicious steak back in there too bad
I'm sorry chica I'm sorry those look
really good I want one no you can't have
one either
it's even torture
no yes no Ethan doesn't have it she
could just come here and sit we have to
I'm so sorry
I've ever got a hat please chica is a
good girl she deserves the world but
without your donations we're gonna cook
it right now we're gonna get through
with it we're gonna see what anything is
gonna put on Oh
we doesn't need any seasoning what do
you mean yeah see I think probably bad
for her oh yeah our olives okay for dogs
because we do need the oil the pan yeah
but you guys please chief or this no
one's happy no no we're not happy I
personally not no definitely not happy
definitely I'm happy so please if you
care about chica if you care about us if
you care about children sure make a
donation now get us to this next
threshold or cheek no pets no pets it
might have to start during the next one
cuz it will take a while to cook through
that oh well it could be fairly rare for
dogs yeah I just want to mmm I got the
lid and everything Oh what are we even
at right now what are we
[Applause]
very tortured our know the tip rule the
temporary torture chica no no no so
close it's so close but I put it I put
it up alright so it tell that a bazooka
has to stay there and look at it but
we're gonna carry on we're gonna start
doing some body art we're gonna try to
get some joy in our hearts and carry on
with this next challenge oh it's okay
it's alright she's running from her
sadness alright how's that looking Tyler
I've got one side seared I'm gonna sear
it all the way around should be alright
alright so it's a lid searing hold on
man well while you get that I'll grab
some of some of these oh so what we have
here is we have we have blow pens so if
you know what blow pens are we've got a
whole bunch of uh if I can hold them
we've got a whole bunch of stencils here
look at all these nifty little stencils
that we cut out we've got a we've got
dinosaurs we've got cool robots we've
got a cool car there's there's a bunch
more down there we've got letters
numbers everything that you could ever
imagine and then we've got in these pens
I've never used both hands before
I think you just blow uh don't belong
the mic oh that's so cool
alright alright who's going first I'll
wait for no so here's how it's gonna
work
we are each Tyler and I are gonna have a
turn
blowing alright are we gonna do it in
the same fire is it
hang on I'm explaining it say hi you
were gonna say no oh no no no no you
don't know how he's gonna say Tyler and
I are going to take turns with these
blow pens blowing art on Ethan and then
Ethan and Tyler will blow me okay then I
and Ethan will blow Tyler art and the
judging isn't who does the best art
because art once you make it is released
into the world it's no longer yours once
it's interpreted by other people
whatever then the person who has the
best art on their body on their shirt
wins wait do they get punished yes no
worst art gets punished but that's
weight on the shirt yeah we're trying to
be bad no see you want your shirt to be
good so it's not bad yeah what if it's
my shirt yeah but that's what the double
blind
the same Pepsi it's foolproof I really
thought these things up huh oh yeah I
did
oh boy okay all right well let's do this
Tyler is that steak ready I got one more
little flip to see your side and how to
the donation are we so let me give you a
waft of it do you smell that
do you smell it chica you know no save
us from ourselves we've got the nice
smell Irwin honey no even worse Oh oh
that's nice isn't it that's nice oh no
GU can you pat me of it you cannot has
okay
all right let's do some art I know a
body paint that is true we definitely do
have body am i keeping these on for this
you can take them off now I can I think
I think you've had enough I've had it on
for quite a while yeah you bad enough
you're good please please help chica
she's so hungry hope she could get her
steak disappear
poor trainers we made her hungry and she
had to some dry food instead of the
fresh delicious steak they're waiting
for her our donate now we got to keep
moving
you're a good girl chica oh that's so
far ooh there's been another thousand
1050 Britt Oh brick
wait yeah we're gonna follow her trip
i'll i'll be i'll be i'll be that we
were you were first how like mark
explained it all right cool
where's i got a pick a color the thing
is to put the muscle stems on no okay so
you pulled this out we got extra you
pull this out you think separate like
yeah we got it
no oh it's over here hey wait alright no
we got extra we're gonna mark it goes
this way no other way yeah like that and
you put the big cap on this set yeah you
blow through the black ah okay like this
guy even get over okay I'm coming
waiters you blow through the mm-hmm the
colored - mm-hmm okay alright you ready
sorry just like I'm on my way colors
flip probably yet Tyler what oh that's
the better part of me
debatable are you see there's no good
party thing I mean no anymore
yeah mmm it's so sticky
okay I'm on my way my arms still feel
like there's things all right you can do
this on my body if he likes
brif yeah yeah brief has got to be on
the body but we lookin well blow pen how
much can I blow it once
that's the question here oh yeah wait I
gotta do a test blow here we go
that's one man powerful enough to blow
this much pen here do it on the blank
right yeah are you doing a quarter ok a
little bit well da future canvas do okay
sorry alright
where would you like it don't block that
camera I'm sorry I'm
all right riff I'm gonna I got this I'm
gonna do on the other side of Bjorn here
okay all right
[Music]
hey Griffith hey breath thank you for
the donation hey live riff hey riff hey
library
thanks Vic slow I blew a better heart
than you drew that's true
thank you for if so much you're awesome
thank you for it all right so how much
time should we have to make this we
should get it we should get a fork and a
knife because she probably should not
eat all of that all I was gonna rip it
with my hands okay chica chica oh my
goodness
Oh chica we love you so much Oh chica
would you like some steak all right not
too much you might get sick if you too
much okay we'll save some for later
last one okay sit let's let's show the
stream how good a dog you are all right
cheetah sit paw down good oh that's a
good girl
oh you're a good girl good girl good
girl we'll give you them later I don't
want you to get sick okay all right good
oh but unfortunately we need another
punishment here well Bob all right dude
very voluntary all right so you go lay
down we'll carry on with the stupidity
we're sorry they torture you I think you
chose it no no no turtle boy oh nice
that is really
all right which one do you want him to
get well I'm just shocked how long we
shot this open oh well well then I want
him to get to that car good luck use
your big mouth big mouth oh good night
not your little mouth use your big yo
your big mouth okay your big boy mouth
come on yeah I got a come on dude that's
a big boy music mouth you used to blast
bugles Bigley yeah come on boys
big dance boy did you see the numbers
yeah you bet you got it you got it come
on mom come on get that Apple that's
some water there's a lot of pure water
there forward there you go you're on an
Apple I hope you can feel that bite it
bite it push it against the side you can
use your nose to direct it to a penguin
army yeah get that snoot to direct it
bite this just sad at this boy come on
come on come on come on come on come on
get it it bad there you go that's a big
boy bite it doesn't babe just shove your
head all the way to the bottom press
against it inviting you can do it I
believe do we have a time limit for
Bobby before he has a bob again
[Laughter]
[Music]
bite it we should have gotten
long-stemmed ones for Ethan's baby mouth
ah oh you got it cold hands ah
not all of us okay so here's how this
one works we're gonna put more ice in
that thing we're gonna put it back no
leave it out yeah gross wait you're
gonna do we wanted to try and do it then
no no that's already got water and we
need to beat reais so what we're gonna
do cold hands is we have to do the next
challenge with one hand in a cold bucket
so we're gonna drag that in front and
we're gonna have to blow with one hand
in the bucket of ice it's not really a
oh you've actually is bad do I get one
side yeah okay just cuz Bob's right go
get some ice and ice we're we're gonna
do body art soon I swear I swear we're
gonna it's happening we're not stalling
for time as so many amazing things are
happening but remember please keep
making donations we have so far to go we
are actually a quarter to our goal which
means that if we get to 200,000 that
means we've actually raised $400,000 so
we are already a quarter of her way to a
goal we've only been streaming for about
an hour and a half right yeah we've
raised $50,000 in an hour and a half
that is outrageous that is incredible
and we're gonna keep that pace up so
long as you guys help us along the way
keep sharing the stream keep telling
everybody about what's going on here and
we will oh your hands inside this
affects us in more than just the ice
yeah yeah it's gonna be colder for Bobby
yeah exactly it's gonna be fun all right
so I got my colors I think I just kind
of picked up well all of them should
just be in a collective pile okay all
right then all right
oh man so we all agree we're trying our
best we're not gonna yeah go sabotage
all right do we do we have a theme do
you want a theme maybe we should have a
theme what theme I don't know maybe they
can decide this is something to
philosophy no time for that time is it
we barely have 30 minutes yeah we got
yeah we got a good I'm sorry yeah all
right all right so oh yeah wait who's
going first you okay I got it
you got a you've already got this I like
Alyssa
you want something under your knee
colored comments no I'm pre can you
notice a pillow just throws a pillow a
couple knows what I'm gonna need okay
I'm gonna need it to yeah uh yeah I know
that's behind me but it's wet this is if
you need it now or not do you want to
know sure okay it's here okay I'm gonna
all right yeah trying to stencils we got
temporary tattoos just yeah mark let's
make him space ooh
do we have yeah I mean you can do
whatever we gotta have like seven
minutes
no God no that's all three minutes three
minutes three minutes sounds very good
all right cool all right ready dude did
we pick the theme of space uh here's
some space stuff well there's only so
much you can just have my car this could
be Spacey I got alright ready I need
colors over here well oh here's more
colors
alright go here take them one hand in go
oh hold this alright I hold you blow I
hold you blow harder oh this is going
wow this is cold is it fun really is it
that cold use the blue the blue use the
blue to look for me mmm very nice blue
there's a nice blue alright switch hands
oh good golly Miss Molly
Oh mark we need to get some on there let
me blow something blow comment I what
[Laughter]
it's funny took home not great oh it's
just not good hey I'll hold up the
dragon
oh nice to be the Sun doesn't matter how
fast he goes cuz it's a time limit silly
man hahaha it's a little bit of funny
feeling huh oh one minute
Oh Oh God I'm not in any way
exaggerating about this oh I got it oh
I'm not exaggerating I'm not anything
that hurts don't all right bud oh so bad
why it's so painful why are eating Ed's
hands not in here but my shirt no I'm
like a lizard in the desert but it's not
our desert it's the tundra there's a
space come it hold it hold it
thirty seconds nope I'm not super
impressed with my shirt so far this one
say I don't know how good this is gonna
come out I just don't I just don't know
because they're using all sorts of
different colors they're mixing and
matching which you know it uses many
colors as you want but there's gotta be
some method to the madness now what is
that oh oh my god
all right who's up next oh not it
alright so you're here oh oh
no no okay oh my hand recovers it is so
pro yeah oh my god 'make haha maybe
she'll make a donation tell you funny
about our pain smash that Bell please
reach the next goal so this can go away
ah okay we I'm not joking about any of
this this really hurts I don't even know
cuz usually like if you put salt in this
it'll be like super painful but oh it's
so painful huh we're gonna get frostbite
from this dream no we're not gonna get
frostbite but it's very painful
Ethan yeah you want to just do a nose I
mean I feel like we should just do it
ever really want keep in mind this is a
lovely super mega shirt so you tarnish
it if you don't improve it I'm gonna be
very upset
well that was your fault I have an idea
if I get I bought like three of these so
I guess it's okay okay okay all right
Ethan can I can I have a blue before we
start a blue okay ready all right
these run out pretty quick by the way
the gray no longer works there's body
page 20 where's the muddy pain you're so
strong Tyler you're so strong
whenever everybody's ready all right we
might I might need your help holding
here see this is just relaxing at this
point I'm gonna have been a lovely time
so hey have you guys have you guys made
your donations yet have you guys
contributed to save the children
yeah hold it up I'm driving ever because
it's a wonderful organization that helps
children all around the world we're
trying to ride tear in my arm dollars by
ourselves but that you Andrew thousand
dollars is gonna be matched 100% for a
total of four hundred thousand possible
dollars raised and at the pace we're
going we're gonna meet that goal but we
can only get there with your help so if
you guys continue to help us raise money
and help us by sharing this
and telling people about this cause we
can keep rolling here and hopefully we
can hit another goal where we have to do
a different punishment that's not this
one because this is a really painful one
how you guys doing down there it's not
bad shut your gob all here hold on wait
I'm going to fill your cup don't fill my
gobble it is that come on you even we
need to need to drop
I've got beefy German hands with a lot
of blood flow I think that's it I'm not
a big baby I'm not saying I'm a big baby
it it hurt it hurt a lot I want to be
very clear to hurt a lot Ethan's
cheating because of his gymnast hands my
gymnast which he's beat to a pulp over
his life and he has no feeling left in
him
that's why number one that's why he's
bad at video games and number two that's
why you can't it's cuz you're gymnasts
and they're just dead sacks of meat at
the end of your arms they're useless
limp noodles doing brushes why would we
have brushes what are you doing you're
going free hand I'm going that dinosaur
than a man why do you paint
I mean artists use whatever median it's
not about the tool it's about the artist
right it is what are you trying to do I
don't know well then why did you start
well because art is about exploration is
it not exploring what though exploring
my inner self in my dreams but why are
you doing that on me well you're the
only canvas I had that's so sweet thank
you that's the evil man fighting superb
dude okay thank you see it's super mega
that's right yeah what is that pieces
you leave me to drink no we're leaving
him to dry
aha it's a art pun about thing Hey I
don't know I don't know about this guy's
yeah that was bad yeah I'm pretty sure
this is awful
oh my hey you guys screw the switch to
the other side the superhero is pretty
cool
no I'm pretty good pretty good all right
uh let's see what do I want to do for
this one oh oh yes oh yes I know what I
want to do okay I already know I got it
I don't have to hold mine because I'm
nice and tight real proud of I'm really
proud II had a hair in my mouth see bad
well yeah like it it was bad it wasn't
comfortable but it wasn't like screaming
in pain Oh baby okay colder for us we
wore what's up with our warm hands yeah
what whoa we need a saying let's go
through this real quick because we got
to finish this or else we're gonna round
time for this section can be the theme
of my shirt
Oh No okay all right ready yeah okay
through this that tickles that's weird
it's like air just on my snip hang on
like it way flat
I didn't hear you grunting in right here
why are you groaning cuz it tickles hmm
a letter for your boy
yes I will yes I will yes I will ow ow
ow ow it hurts show better it doesn't
hurt when I'm blowing you know that I
didn't know and that's that's an
intriguing thing I'm really I'm really
gonna feel like I'm kind of being
sabotage trite now I totally feel like
this is full saboteur what I mean it's
totally art but I don't I don't know
there's not burrowing maybe it looks
like the market needs to be pushed in
further this game is crap Oh every time
I stop blowing it suddenly hurts but
when I'm in my in the middle of my art
this is Garbo why is it not
where's it not blow bow okay ah well I
just wet it so that that ain't gonna
help nobody here where ah good yeah hang
on
well please please please Pete I get one
thing okay Erica nice nice
this is good stuff good stuff mark thank
you okay all right
it's just groaning why are you ruining I
don't know if I'm groaning how am i
groaning you are who drips you dripped
on me you dripped on your shelf okay
that did not drip off it doesn't hurt
when I'm blowing it only when I stop
blowing it it's a breathing exercise
[ __ ] oh it was weird when I was in my
art mold it's painful I got paint in the
bucket got a lot of paint in the bucket
good thing body paint is non-toxic
oh I I actually wiped off a lot of them
art so okay
hope hope all right Oh would you like
[Music]
it's right here okay thank you so much
for the $1,000 it's a big contribution
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay thank you
were there any other big donations okay
all right what do we add actually
[Music]
awesome we've still got what time is it
right now
okay so we needed a judge oh yeah no no
viewers at home judge a donation yeah I
can't tell if I make a poll and there's
a poll up there but it's for the final
thing straw poll would be yes if you
guys donate right now right in your
comment section of the donation who has
the best shirt right now get together
yes it's a good name yeah the name of
the person just the name of the person
with the best shirt right now not who
made the best shirt but it was currently
wearing the best shirt and I gotta admit
you got the right color scheme you got
the right like unification this has the
most like color and that's all over the
place garbage at least mine's like kind
of themed this I don't know but actually
just you rub off yeah I need your art
rubs off on others I just have that kind
of personality the what good oh it's an
evil face Hey no this is kind of cool
looks like a stitch smiley face yeah
anyway so if you guys can write the name
of the person who has the best shirt
right now that'll be the winner and then
the person who loses bye see ya we come
back to punish me oh yeah we'll come
back to the punishment what we'll do
Bob in this yeah righty-ho righty-ho oh
yeah who wants to get us to win and
where we go and what we do and why we're
here and who I am and what shirt is the
best for Q and save the children we love
you always and no one will stop us from
have baby shirts on sale to date that's
a lie I really promise that thing here
horn Jim say things we don't like
thank you was there any me alright
alright looks like I want what come on
take a look we got some nice body paint
through what you got you oh wait a
second Ethan went and danger territory
with his blows that's fine
see I had the strategy of holding it in
my mouth when I was blowing so whatever
whatever okay all right all right I
guess I lose then yeah look up for your
love yeah all right I guess if we really
care about these super expensive loved
one bull [ __ ] all right so what donation
total over yet whoa keep those donations
going let's see what happens I love that
there's paint in this now and a nice hey
it's not too bad I'm gonna try and get
the edge so you don't get it all over
your head how oh I know what's an apple
and what's ice the size no by the taste
[Laughter]
did you watch your eyes all right good
okay you want me to go for another one
yeah
[Laughter]
I'm sorry that might have been a good
one
you're honest at least girl actually I
was hoping you get that hope hey
remember don't see any use for games oh
that is perfect for the next one
actually okay don't don't forget your
spaghetti duh duh duh don't forget your
spaghetti is a game where I made this up
like all these where we are each given a
bowl of spaghetti and then the bull is
taken away we have to hold that
spaghetti until the end of the round all
the way at the hour passes in the next
game whoever has the most amount of
spaghetti left not only wins that or
they win that and then also the winner
of the challenge is exempt from the
punishment so whoever has the least
amount of spaghetti has to Bob and the
loser has to Bob so there's two
potential Bob's in addition to all the
other punishments that we have for the
next one make sense yeah yeah
all right so we'll be doing that in the
next one but remember guys we're here to
raise money for Save the Children work
everything needs double I'm gonna hound
you guys about this because we have a
long way to go we may have raised fifty
seven thousand dollars but that is only
a quarter of the way to our goal and we
have done technically a quarter of the
challenges that we're gonna be doing
today so we're relying on you guys to
help us out I'm gonna be making a
donation in between this and the next
one I hope you guys make a donation in
fact here's what I'll do
since it's in the in the nature of
matching whatever you guys donate from
the time this stream goes off to the
time it comes back on I will match in a
personal donation what it will triple so
whatever you donate in the next span
will triple because not only will I be
matching but the anonymous donator will
be matching as well now that will start
as soon as we cut off the stream for
this one and then move on to the next
challenge
and then we will continue that and I
will make my donation either before or
just as we're going into the next stream
make sense everybody yes okay so this
has been fun I blame them for my
failures as always but thank you so much
we are not done for the day we have six
more challenges that we're gonna be
doing if you want to see them make sure
to bring that notification belts are you
gonna notification what we're going up I
do not have my phone right now so I
cannot tweet out exactly when we go up
each time but we will hopefully rectify
that solution so that you guys begin the
notification there as well but thank you
guys we got a long way to go it's gonna
be super fun chika appreciates it and
everyone here is grateful she's taking a
nice I just had steak nap oh that's so
sweet so we'll be back in just over 30
minutes thank you guys again we'll see
you soon donate please whatever you do
I'll match well baby it's a triple Oh